[Musique]
je ne veux pas chasser
les terres du front
sionnel je veux chasser le front
national de ses terres j'y mettrai toute
mon énergie
parce que je crois que le front national
est dangereux mortifère l'obsession
pouces et dupond moretti a à mon égard
commence à devenir relativement étrange
il paraît qu'il reste quelques bracelets
anti-rapprochement en rab
je suis preneuse voilà une phrase qui en
digne à gauche au sein du gouvernement
quelques jours après le féminicide de
mérignac
un peu de décence en rab peut-être
madame a tweeté la secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
marlène schiappa dans cette famille ils
ont un goût de la blague douteuse et du
calembour de mauvaise facture
je trouve ça d'une indécence mais
incroyable mais chez dupont moretti
avait fait un tweet quelques heures
avant pour dire que sur 1000 bracelet
anti rapprochement seuls 63 avaient été
distribués si je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose d'indécent l'indécence elle se
situe ici je préférerais qu'ils croisent
le fer avec les voyous je veux dire le
problème
on a quand même un pays aujourd'hui ou
comme le reconnaissent tous les français
il ya un problème d'ordre public de
justice tout le monde a bien compris qui
était monsieur dupont moretti
c'est un obsessionnel c'est un matamore
vantaa mais le résultat de son ministère
en dehors de ce qu'il peut raconter
et bien je peux vous dire que c'est nul
dans ma famille et moi madame
personne n'a commis torture qu'est ce
qui choque seul angle mais c'est
l'incroyable violence c'est la volonté
de diviser c'est le mépris à l'égard de
millions d'électeurs c'est l'insultent
permanente
je crois qu'on avait un garde des sceaux
qui devaient se mobiliser pour renforcer
les moyens de la justice et paix du
christ qu'il s'implique aussi en avant
des sceaux qui devaient travailler sur
un sujet sensible qui était celui d'une
réforme pénale on a un garde des sceaux
qui du jour au lendemain s'improvise
candidat dans l'outrance très bien très
bien
simplement il me semblait que la justice
était un sujet sérieux dans ce pays si
vous croyez qu'on peut se permettre en
ce moment d'avoir des ministres de
l'intérieur ou de la justice à temps
partiel voilà ça veut dire que pendant
six semaines au lieu de s'occuper de la
délinquance qui dégradent notre pays bas
ils font faire les marchés c'est
sympathique les marchés ce surplus
d'énergie ne devrait pas le mettre dans
leur portefeuille
ils ont suffisamment d'énergie pour les
doutes sur ces quelques semaines de
campagne qui nous sépare de certains
disaient le contraire quelques semaines
non je vous dis encore une fois qu'ils
soient d'avoir quelques pas du va se
faire plier
parce que il représente à peu près tout
ce que les gens les avocats fort en
gueule bavard injurieux de paris avec
christian estrosi je me rappelle ce
qu'en 1988 il a été élu président de la
fédération rpr des alpes maritimes
je me rappelle ces combats il était très
très à droite à l'époque est ce qu on
lui répondait vous savez c'est justement
parce que ces mensonges ces fakes et
insulte ses anathèmes ces calomnies
je les entends depuis des années j'ai
résisté
je ne les accepte plus et puis en
réalité aujourd'hui il constate ce qu'on
savait tous et ils disent qu'on savait
tous ça fait quatre ans qu'il est chez
emmanuel macron avignon cet après-midi
5000 personnes se sont réunies devant le
commissariat pour rendre hommage au
brigadier éric masson il était là
lorsque le policier éric masson c
et thierry tu mercredi à avignon elle a
vu l'assaillante j'ai flippé
je me suis dit comment te dire mon dieu
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui s'est passé
quoi je me suis content ya plus de bruit
je me suis levé je suis allé voir et
c'était il y avait deux personnes qui
faisait le massage cardiaque
[Musique]